jennifer aniston and david schwimmer are
addressing those romance rumors after
admitting to having major crushes on
each other during the friends reunion on
hbo max the first season we i had a
major crush on jen
on monday closer claimed that the
reunion quote stirred up feelings for
the former co-stars and that they've
been spending time together at her home
but now a source tells e.t that jen and
david are not dating and are not
romantically involved what do we do with
that information now reps for both
actors also told huffington post uk that
the romance reports are not true e.t has
reached out to both of the actors reps
for comment
i'm sorry that's all the time we have no
kidding
i'm sorry
okay go on back in may jen and david who
shared an on-screen romance in the hit
90s sitcom as ross geller and rachel
green basically
lately i've uh
i've sort of had feelings for you
admitted that all that on-screen heat
translated off-screen too after the
reunion host james gordon asked them
this you're all
young good-looking actors and it's
inconceivable to me that there weren't
perhaps off-screen romances
well
i mean david yeah
yeah i mean the
first season yeah the first season we i
had a major crush on jen
um i and yeah and i think we both
reciprocate yeah and it didn't stop
there at some point we were both
crushing hard on each other but it was
like two ships passing because
one of us was always in a relationship
so and we never crossed that boundary
you know we respected that and but we
both
[Applause]
so the two say they never actually
hooked up behind the scenes but their
cast mates were totally in on their
secret crushes
i thought back on the very first year or
two you know when we have breaks from
rehearsal like there were moments we
would like cuddle on a couch or
something
and i'm thinking
how did not everyone know we had we're
crushing on each other
we knew we knew we knew for sure great i
just want you to know
last night
i'll never forget it
neither will i
and remember that steamy first kiss in
the coffee house
the now 52 year old actress recalled a
combo she had with the now 54 year old
actor before they shot that on-screen
smooch i remember
saying one time to david it's gonna be
such a bummer if the first time you and
i actually kiss is going to be on
national television
sure enough
first time we kissed
was in that coffee shop
hang on but so we just channeled all of
our adoration and love for each other
into ross and rachel
but that electric chemistry extended way
past just jen and david shortly after
filming the reunion the cast opened up
to et about how their friends on camera
and off we really grew close as a family
and part of the reason was that
that initial success of the show
was something that no other no one else
could relate to or or was going through
except the other five actors so um we
really we really got close because of
that experience too there was something
that was laid down at the very very
beginning that kind of went into our
neural pathways that we instantly it was
in our dna that we were family we were
going to take care of each other
we're the most grateful women that i
know who have been able to be a part of
something like this
[Music]
you